sean presented a very
natural approach to fragment assembly
i on the other hand will present a very
unnatural approach to genome assembly
and we will debate later
whose approach is better the first thing
to notice
that in fact there are two
hamiltonian passes in the graph that
shown
presented this is the first one and this
is the second one
and while sean presented his very
natural approach
it's absolutely unclear how to find
either of these passes i will do
something different first i will
slightly modify
the graph remember in the hamiltonian
path problem
we put three mers into
uh nodes of the graph in
contrary i will represent every edge of
my graph
as a trimmer see this almost cosmetic
difference it's not clear
why do i care so much about this
difference
at the moment if we label the edges of
the graph let's also try to label
nodes of the graph and how should we
label the nodes
of the edge taa let's label the starting
node by the prefix of ta and let's label
the ending node by the suffix of taa
as a result we will have this graph
shown below here it's a path currently
not a graph yet
and this is our starting point this
path labeled by streamers
where edges are labeled by swimmers and
nodes are labeled by
tumors and now we'll do something
very strange with this graph let's glue
identically labeled nodes in the graph
in this graph we have three nodes
labeled 80
let's glue them together let's bring two
of them next to each other
and next let's bring three of them next
to each other
let's bring them even closer to each
other and finally
they will glue in a single vertex as
shown
at this slide now
we haven't done yet because there are
more identically labeled nodes in this
graph
here it is three nodes labeled tg let's
bring them closer together
and finally they will be glued into the
same nodes
are we done not yet there are two more
nodes
that are identically labeled these are
two nodes bring them closer together
and glue them in a single node the
result
is the graph that we will be studying in
this lecture lot
it is called debris graph of a string
and the question that we
first should ask how does this graph can
help us
to find the genome where is the gene of
hiding in this graph
it isn't hiding at all because we
started from the genome
to construct this graph we just made
some operations
to make the genome somewhat illusive in
this graph but it is there it was
always there let's take a look what
correspond to the genome in this graph
of course it is the path that we were
growing that goes like this
this this this and as we
walk along the graph this slowly but
surely
builds a strength the original strength
that was used
let's continue doing this continue doing
this what are we trying to do
well since we need to explain all
streamers
in the graph what we are trying to do is
to find
a person's graph that visits every edge
streamer exactly once let's continue
and after we finish this we construct
actually something that we call an
already
path a path that visits
every edge in the graph exactly once
and now we have already in path problem
that is attributed to euler of course
find an online path in the graph which
is a path
visiting every node exactly once
and as you remember euler solves this
problem trying to solve the seven
bridges of carrick's back problems this
is an
ancient map of koenigsberg and the
orange dot on this map is exactly
where i took you to the field trip now
what
euler did he constructed a graph
by connecting four nodes in this graph
each node
corresponds to a district of the city by
a natch
if there is a corresponding bridge
between these two
districts in the city it is an
undirected graph
in difference from directed graphs that
we mainly consider it in this lesson
but it doesn't matter that much the
differences between directed and
undirected graphs are small
and we will be mainly working with this
directed graphs
and will let you a chance to implement
whatever
other problems for direct for undirected
graph
so we now have two problems already and
past problem
and hamiltonian path problem do you find
many differences here and the question
arises
why did i waste your time reformulating
the problems that sean already presented
what was
my goal and in the next segment i will
give the answer to this question